good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight for centuries America fought
crime by hiring police but now Democrats
have a new plan fire the police and
redefine law-breaking as an act of
virtue if there's no enforcement there's
no crime well with shocking speed it has
become normal on the left to demand the
abolition of ice and the 20,000 agents
who work therein enforce our immigration
laws just a few weeks ago it was only a
few activists on the far left you were
calling for this and then this week on
Tuesday congressional candidate
Alexandria Acacio Cortez won a
Democratic primary against Joe Crowley
in New York she ran on abolishing ice
and now in a flash ambitious Democrats
are scrambling aboard the bandwagon last
night for example senator and career
opportunities Kirsten Gillibrand of New
York said that she favors abolishing ice
the opposite of her opinion from a few
years ago
Kamla Harris of California says she's
open to that as well bill de blasio the
mayor of New York has also called for
abolishing ice so I have seven Democrats
in the house this is gathering steam
this idea and yet no one who's
advocating for it seems to be thinking
even for a moment about what the effect
would be if we abolished ice for example
as we speak millions of people want to
enter this country the entire city of
Tijuana Mexico has already filled with
tens of thousands of would-be asylum
seekers from all over the world Central
America Africa everywhere as well as as
many as a half a million people who've
been deported from the United States
the net effect Tijuana is not a pleasant
place to live what will happen when
words gets out that nobody in any
country on the globe has anything to
fear from our immigration authorities if
you can make it past our Border Patrol
and get a tourist visa you can overstay
and you can never be deported once
people know that how many people will
move here illegally every year a million
five million ten million who knows how
many there might be criminals or
extremists or future welfare dependence
we don't know that either we do know it
won't be long if that happens until
dozens of US cities resemble what
Tijuana looks like right now
none of these new anti-ice lawmakers
seem to be asking any of these questions
they don't seem to care what the answers
might be because they're irrelevant they
know that if we abolish ice and our
borders become irrelevant they'll get
what they want a new body of voters who
can shove aside the Troublesome people
who are already American citizens the
people demanding the abolition of ice
aren't looking out for those ordinary
Americans don't want ice abolished a new
poll from Harvard shows that even 60% of
Democrats don't want ice abolished it's
a radical position but it's also the new
normal on the left